bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir les etats-unis sommes
l'alertent depuis des semaines
maintenant sur une offensive imminente
de la russie vers l'ukraine on l'a vu
les propos se sont faits plus alarmiste
encore ces dernières 24 heures quelle
est la posture la des américains et
comment selon vous réagissent les russes
en retour eux qui démentent depuis des
semaines toutes velléités offensives
bonsoir effectivement nous avons vu ces
derniers temps une accélération de la
posture agressive américaine qui semble
avoir la tentation de effectivement
provoquer un scénario militaire je dis
bien provoquer parce qu'il n'est pas
évident du tout qu'ils interviennent
directement en fait d'après le
renseignement militaire russes il y
aurait de nombreux groupes djihadistes
qui vont débarquer sur la ligne de fond
côté ukrainien et l'on peut craindre
effectivement qu'il y ait des
provocations qui soient mises en oeuvre
maintenant il faut comprendre que
ces provocations ont une chance d'être
réalisé si les états unis ont la
certitude que la russie n'interviendra
pas pour défendre le donbass parce que
soyons très clairs si les états unis ont
envie de gagner cette guerre très
concrètement et de récupérer
physiquement le territoire du dombass
ils n'ont pas envie de mener cette
guerre donc beaucoup va dépendre aussi
de l'attitude de la russie qui jusqu'à
présent en tout cas aujourd'hui a
parfaitement tenu l'espèce d'assaut
diplomatique qui a été menée par les
chancelleries occidentales
et
semble résister et plus sa position sera
forte et plus il y aura des chances que
se confirmer n'ait pas lieu pour
washington les manoeuvres militaires de
la russie sont le signe de la
préparation d'une opération russe en
ukraine où washington qui répond donc en
envoyant des soldats américains dans les
pays alliés d'autant qu'elle est votre
regard
de la même manière dans ce cas-là l'on
peut considérer que la présence
militaire étrangère en ukraine et
programmes de l'otan les nombreuses
manoeuvres à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de chez eux que sont ces
militaires aux frontières de la russie
sont un signe d'agression prochaine
d'aidé l'otan vers la russie donc soyons
un peu sérieux on ne va pas non plus
tourner les choses à l'extrême il ya
effectivement un rapport de force chacun
montre ses muscles mais la décision du
conflit face à face n'a pas encore été
prise même si manifestement la tentation
côte est américaine devient très très
importante besoin entretien téléphonique
donc pour vladimir poutine dont la
journée avec emmanuel macron puis joe
biden est ce que la désescalade et la
baisse des tensions est possible comment
est ce que vous voyez les volumes sur la
situation dans les prochaines heures les
prochains jours
d'une manière ou d'une autre il va bien
falloir que cette montée en puissance en
quelque sorte abouti sur quelque chose
parce que nous assistons effectivement
ces dernières 24 heures à une poussée
extrême de 6 que ressemble réellement à
une opération spéciale l'on voit
effectivement que la diplomatie est
devenue un instrument de guerre en tout
cas dans la stratégie américaine et sur
quoi cela va-t-il débouchés les pays
européens ont ici à un rôle sérieux
jouer puisque il n'est absolument pas du
tout de leur intérêt de voir a confié
armée se débloquer aux frontières et il
me semble que jusqu'à présent
malheureusement le passage je ne veux
pas parler du passage de la diplomate
britannique
mais en tout cas disons que
nos chefs d'états nos diplomaties
européennes manifestement ne sont pas à
la hauteur et c'est extrêmement
regrettable parce que ils ont réellement
un rôle à jouer rappelant que l'intérêt
est justement de garder des relations
pacifiques avec la russie qui ne cherche
pas un conflit armé avec qui ne cherche
pas un conflit avec eux mais au
contraire une coopération et l'intérêt
des pays européens n'est pas d'être
instrumentalisés dans un jeu atlantiste
et globalisme et c'est justement de
défendre les intérêts de l'europe et
c'est l'occasion peut-être de le montrer
seront ils à la hauteur pour l'instant
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas on
l'a vu en les pourparlers se multiplient
depuis des jours voire des semaines
entre moscou et les occidentaux
américains autant en pays européens où
est-ce que ça bloque aujourd'hui
toujours sur le même point ça bloque
toujours sur le même point parce que
nous sommes dans une logique de conflit
ne sommes pas dans une logique
réellement diplomatique j'ai dit la
diplomatie ici est utilisé comme un
instrument de combat donc le problème
est que il ne peut pas y avoir de
objectivement et c'est vrai il peut pas
y avoir de consensus d'un côté ou de
l'autre puisque tout compromis serait
une défaite on ne peut pas à la fois
accepté un monde global east et ce qui
est posée par les états unis est laissée
à la russie le droit d'avoir un intérêt
vital et de le défendre la firme et et
la russie ne peut pas à la fois défendre
sa souveraineté est acceptée l'intérêt
globaliste de la même manière que le don
bassin se retrouve pris entre ces deux
de conflit puisque d'un côté les accords
de miss certes ont été conclu il ya sept
ans depuis le temps a passé le situation
de complètement différente il n'est pas
certain du tout que la population dans
le donbass est envie de revenir dans le
cren après avoir été pendant sept ans
prise en otage par pièce par kiev et
agressé donc il y à une impasse en
quelque sorte et
il va falloir à un moment donné
réellement se poser la question est ce
que cela vaut la peine d'une guerre
puisque n'oublions pas quand même que la
guerre au delà peut-être du côté
romantique est intéressant que les
conseillers de byden peuvent-ils trouver
c'est la mort de personne c'est la
destruction de pays et s'appelle la
destruction des civilisations à mon avis
c'est vrai mérite quand même d'y
réfléchir merci beaucoup pour votre
regard karine bcgo love qu'aux
professeurs en vitesse à l'université
d'état de moscou